Ganondorf King of the Gerudo the human
form of the dark Beast Ganon the demon
Thief himself is back and it's certainly
been a while we last Saw ganondorf's
human form causing trouble back in 2006
Twilight Princess where he was defeated
by Link and Princess Zelda but naturally
his fingerprints are all over the
convoluted Zelda timeline and with tears
of the Kingdom Reviving The Ginger devil
what better time to refresh yourself on
the history of the Legend of Zelda's
iconic villain so from his Origins
within the desert dwelling Gerudo tribe
through to his return in tears of the
Kingdom this is the complete timeline of
Ganondorf
[Music]
first things first the basics Ganon or
Ganondorf is featured in a multitude of
different forms and geysers across the
franchise which can confuse things
slightly so let's break down the key
differences between your ganons
giganendorfs and even your Calamity
ganons for starters Ganondorf is the
true human form of the iconic villain a
man born into the desert dwelling
female-centric Gerudo tribe upon
utilizing the power of the Triforce
Ganondorf is able to transform into the
monstrous pig Beast Ganon who ensure is
a Reincarnation of the original Demon
King demise from Skyward Sword more on
him very shortly and finally there's
Calamity Ganon who is simply put more of
a destructive force of nature
[Music]
we only see this rendition of Ganon in
breath of the wild which is set about 10
000 years into the future and so
presumably Ganon has rejected his
physical form in order to fully commit
to demise's Pure Evil he still looks a
bit like a giant pig though albeit a
Nifty neon pink oh and when he's having
his 100 year long hibernation in breath
of the wild he takes on the form of a
creepy spider-like monster too so add
that to the pile
[Music]
while Ganondorf doesn't come into the
complex Zelda Timeline until Ocarina of
Time his Origins actually start right
back at the very beginning of it all
with the cheerful tale of demise
[Music]
demise was the original flame-haired
Demon King Who Rose from within a great
chasm in the ground at the beginning of
time after a lengthy battle between
demise and the goddess hylia The Demon
King was sealed away but that seal
didn't last after a lengthy hibernation
demise was finally reawakened by his
flamboyant Lieutenant a lad called
girohim during the conclusion of Skyward
Sword but a young hero known as link and
a girl called Zelda who turns out to be
the reborn goddess hylia by the way were
successful in fighting back against
demise and upon his defeat at the hands
of the master sword he poured all his
hatred for hylia and the world into the
iconic blade which kick-started a curse
that would last for eternity
and so the foundation for ganondor's
rise to power was established
[Music]
OK during the era of the hero of time
Ganondorf is Born Into the Gerudo tribe
the desert dwelling people have a
strange tradition that sees one male
born into their tribe every 100 years
and our Ganondorf just so happens to be
that one lad in a century and as per
Gerudo custom this makes him the de
facto leader of the tribe he's raised by
the twin sisters kume and katake AKA
twin Rover and as they are rotten to the
core Ganondorf grows up to be a real bad
egg due due to his possession of rare
magical abilities and an all-consuming
desire for power Ganondorf rallied
against the control of the kingdom of
Hyrule killing and thieving in the name
of the Gerudo who he felt had been
marginalized after a lengthy Civil War
the Garuda tribe eventually swore fealty
to Hyrule and Ganondorf bent the knee to
the king but this act just provided him
with the cover to secretly set an action
his plans to seize the Triforce and
Ganondorf succeeded in this treacherous
plan soon after his duplicitous deal
with the King shadowing young Link and
following him into the sacred realm to
take possession of the Triforce only
when he got his hands on it the Triforce
split into three pieces with only the
Triforce of power remaining in the hands
of the demon Thief His invasion of the
Sacred realm turned Hyrule castle and
the surrounding Town into a hellscape
and Ganondorf went about hunting down
the remaining two Triforce pieces in his
quest to own them all Ganondorf came
back into the path of the hero of time
and Princess Zelda and in his mad
attempts to possess the entire Triforce
he transformed into the dark Beast Ganon
for the very first time
[Music]
and well this is where things get a
little confusing
foreign
oh yep the big timeline split in Zelda
is well documented even by me on this
very Channel and Ganondorf is right at
the heart of it with all the timey
whininess of Ocarina of Time the Zelda
Timeline splits three ways depending on
various outcomes from the climactic
battle between link and Ganondorf
there's the hero is defeated branch and
the hero is triumphant branch which
itself splits two ways following a
timeline where link returns to his
childhood and one which follows on after
he vanishes yeah it's confusing but our
loud Ganondorf or his alter ego Ganon
feature in all three of them so let's
get into it
foreign
let's start with the defeat timeline
Ganondorf is successful in defeating the
hero of time and for his troubles he
takes possession of the full Triforce
which transforms him into his Porky
Beast form Ganon despite his victory
he's still sealed away in the sacred
Realm by its protective sages which
allows a shaky piece to descend on
Hyrule but ganondorf's sheer hatred and
ill will towards the hero of time and
Princess Zelda is enough to ensure that
his imprisonment in the sacred realm
isn't Everlasting and while in the
sacred realm Ganondorf gives it a little
makeover turning the place into the dark
world that players visit in A Link to
the Past
talking of a link to the past that's
where we venture next seeking to break
free of the Dark World Ganon sends the
priest of Darkness agonim to do his
bidding and create a path to Hyrule wide
enough for the giant pig to fit through
only he's once again thwarted by a young
hero dressed in green who defeats him
once and for all while also taking back
possession of the Triforce for the
Hyrule royal family
[Music]
's death the Dark World eventually Fades
away Ganon doesn't stay dead for long
though he's resurrected via a dodgy
ceremony led by his old mates a pair of
twin witches known as twin Rover in the
Oracle games the ceremony itself is
something of a botch job though and twin
Rover end up having to sacrifice
themselves after Link's Intervention
which leads to Ganon returning as a
brainless Pig suffice to say this
version of Ganon does not last long
Ganon is then resurrected once again at
the climax of A Link Between Worlds by
an evil wizard fella called Yuga who
seeks to fuse himself with the giant pig
as a means to save his world of Laurel
at the hands of its more privileged twin
Hyrule once again a young Laden green
Rises to the challenge and overcomes the
revived Ganon once more
but wait there is one more Resurrection
in this branch of the timeline and
that's ganon's appearance in the
original 1986 Legend of Zelda he's
resurrected off screen in this iteration
though and after so many resurrections
he's merely a shadow of his original
human form either way the giant pigs
amassed an army of demons and is stormed
through Hyrule prompting the latest
Princess Zelda to split the Triforce of
wisdom into eight pieces which he
scatters across the land enter link once
again who Hoovers up the Triforce pieces
and definitively destroys Ganon well at
least in this timeline
[Music]
okay let's put the never-ending
resurrections to one side and Rewind
back to the pivotal chronology split at
the end of Ocarina of Time to focus on
the next Branch the child timeline here
we follow the outcome where link is
successful in his fight against
Ganondorf and after having a big old
celebration with Zelda and the sages
returns to his own childhood to warn a
younger Zelda of ganondorf's treachery
this leads to ganondorf's imprisonment
and then eventual execution an event
that we see play out in Twilight
Princess but here's the kicker as link
was in possession of the Triforce of
Courage when he traveled back in time
the remaining pieces found their way
into the hands of Zelda and Ganondorf
respectively and so when he stabbed
through the chest in Twilight Princess
with a great big bloody sword
the Triforce of power protects him what
he's not protected from though is his
subsequent banishment to the Twilight
realm as he did previously with his
exile to the sacred realm Ganondorf
works the new surroundings to his
advantage and he joins forces with an
evil member of the Twilight race known
as Zant with magical powers gifted to
him from Ganondorf sant's influence over
the Twilight realm increases and he
eventually leads an invasion on Hyrule
with the backing of the Demon King Zant
knocks into an entirely new breed of
Link and he's eventually defeated by the
Elfin hero who's aided by another
Twilight known as midna
foreign
but all of this is just subterfuge for
ganondorf's ultimate endgame which is
complete dominion over Hyrule he returns
from the Twilight realm and takes
control of Hyrule castle where he
kidnaps and possesses Princess Zelda but
after three rounds with link one of
which sees the Demon King transform into
Ganon Ganondorf is finally defeated and
in his defeat the Triforce of power
abandons him which ultimately leads to
his death but that's certainly not the
last we'll see of the ginger warlord in
this branch of the timeline oh no
somehow Ganondorf in return yep
Ganondorf returns to cause Havoc several
hundred years later during the events of
four Swords Adventures the Hyrule
Historia simply States he's born into
the world which uh I don't really know
what to make of that either way he's
back and he's pissed he starts by
violating the laws of Gerudo Village by
trespassing into an ancient pyramid and
stealing a powerful Trident before
nicking a dark mirror from the Cheery
sounding Temple of Darkness the story of
four Swords Adventures is a bit of an
afterthought to all the multiplayer
dungeon hopping but in a nutshell
Ganondorf sets about resurrecting the
evil wind Sorcerer of vati who literally
hasn't been seen for Millennia at this
point in the timeline as he sealed
within the fabled 4 sword which itself
also hasn't been seen since way before
Ocarina of Time it prompts a mad
Adventure where link is quadrupled by
the aforementioned blade to save the
lands the links defeat vati in his
Palace of winds which doesn't sound as
intimidating as it's probably meant to
and that prompts Ganondorf to rage out
into full Ganon mode the four links and
Princess Zelda venture defeat the great
big beast with the four sword and that
brings ganondorf's story within the
child Era timeline to a close
[Music]
all of which brings us to the final
branch of the timeline the adult era
like the child ERA this Branch follows
on from the conclusion where link is
successful in his fight against
Ganondorf and the demon king is sealed
away in the sacred realm only this
timeline continues on after the point
where link returned to his childhood
confused join the club anyway many years
later Ganondorf creeps up from the
depths of the Sacred realm to re-carnage
Across the lands of Hyrule again as the
hero of time has vanished from this
timeline the Triforce of Courage is
shattered into eight pieces and spread
across the world and as a result no hero
emerges to save Hyrule from ganondorf's
destructive power this prompts the
reigning king of Hyrule to reach out to
the gods for help their solution is to
flood the entirety of the kingdom of
Hyrule thus sealing Ganondorf away at
the bottom of the ocean hundreds of
years pass and as per usual Ganondorf is
resurrected once again he wastes no time
in murdering a pair of sages who protect
the master sword before taking up
residence in the forsaken Fortress he
uses this foreboding place as a base of
operations for his search for Princess
Zelda and the Triforce of wisdom and he
starts kidnapping young girls from
across the seas in a Relentless bid to
find her but unlucky for him another
young hero garbed in green Rises up to
challenge him and this one's teamed up
with a magnificent talking red boat who
turns out to be The Reincarnation of the
king of Hyrule
this link swans around the oceans
collecting Triforce shards and proving
he's worthy of the Triforce of Courage
all of which leads towards an inevitable
confrontation with the Demon King this
takes place at gannon's Tower which like
the kingdom of Hyrule is currently
resting at the bottom of the ocean and
it's here where the three pieces of the
Triforce are finally reunited with link
bearing the courage section Zelda the
wisdom piece and Ganondorf the power
slab as the unified Triforce grants
Divine wishes to those that touch it
Ganondorf immediately reaches out to it
to fulfill his ultimate goal of Reviving
Hyrule and ruling over it but in that
moment the king of Hyrule rocks up Beats
him to the punch and wishes for Hyrule
to be sealed away forever
and in the ensuing Maelstrom Lincoln
Zelda launch a coordinated attack on
Ganondorf with the full might of the
master sword and Zelda's light arrows
and in his final moments Ganondorf
reveals a core aspect of his motives for
power all along where he says my country
lay within a vast desert when the sun
rose into the sky a burning wind
punished my lands searing the world and
when the moon climbed into the dark of
night a frigid Gale pierced our homes no
matter when it came it carried the same
thing death but the winds that blew
across the green fields of Hyrule
brought something other than suffering
in ruin I coveted that wind I suppose
and with those compelling words still
lingering Ganondorf has turned to stone
and buried at the bottom of the ocean an
act that frees him from his never-ending
lust for power and brings his story in
this branch of the timeline to a close
[Music]
as I mentioned right back at the
beginning of this video the breath of
the wild and tears of the Kingdom era of
the Zelda Timeline actually take place
more than ten thousand years into the
future oh and they supposedly and
somewhat confusingly unite all of the
timeline strands into one chronology
demise's never-ending curse is still
soldiering on though and as a result
Ganon is still being resurrected to
terrorize Hyrule in the prologue to
breath of the wild we learned that Ganon
has become a manifestation of Pure Evil
turning him into the devastating form of
Calamity Ganon this form of Ganon is so
powerful that it requires the sheikah
tribe to create an entire Army of robot
Guardians and four giant Divine beasts
just to keep him at Bay before he's
sealed Away by the latest incarnations
of Link and Zelda fast forward 10
Millennia and Calamity Ganon returns
once again and destroys pretty much all
of central Hyrule Link and Zelda
survived by the Skin of Their Teeth but
Link's wounds are so severe that he
needs to be placed in a shrine of
Resurrection for a century Zelda
meanwhile uses her Divine powers to hold
Calamity Ganon at Bay within Hyrule
Castle Q another time jumped to 100
years later link awakes and takes the
fight to Calamity Ganon eventually
defeating the giant pig monster in the
center of Hyrule
and that pretty much leads us right up
to the point where Link and Zelda
discover ganondorf's desiccated corpse
in a crypt underneath Hyrule Castle in
tears of the Kingdom
as this is a history of Ganondorf video
I'm not going to be going into any
detail on ganondorf's story and tears of
the Kingdom as at the time of this video
is released people will largely be
discovering that for themselves and I
don't want to spoil it I hope you
enjoyed this Ganondorf timeline thank
you so much for watching and I'll see
you next time